je vous en parle enfin après des mois
d'écriture de dessin par paca de
colorisation d'impression de
distribution tout ce que vous voulez le
tome 2 de ma bande dessinée roger et
c'est humain est enfin disponible
partout dans votre librairie votre fnac
cultura votre kebab votre boulangerie
tout ce que vous voulez j'en suis très
très très fier et vous pouvez cliquez
sur lire dans la description qu'ils
voulaient a commandé en ligne c'est
possible également est aussi sans le
dire à personne je travaille sur un
projet qui me tient énormément à coeur
vous avez vu le titre de la vidéo c'est
un petit peu la suite logique après la
bd qui me faisait vraiment rêver je
prépare un dessin animé
roger c'est humain voilà c'est vraiment
incroyable de bossé là-dessus faire les
textes travaillés avec l'animation faire
des voix vous aurez un petit extrait à
la fin de la vidéo mais je sais vous
avez plein de questions et moi j'ai
plein de réponses
alors c'est parti conférence de presse
bonjour à tous merci d'être là voilà
j'en ai place qui veut commencer
oui arthur pour le jour de l'an proxima
sion c'est quoi robert et à ses amis
exactement alors roger et c'est humain
c'est une bd que j'ai écrite et dessinée
par pacal ottoman est sorti il ya trois
ans et j'en suis très fier puisque voilà
c'était un pari de faire une bande
dessinée avec des nouveaux personnages
et pas de faire une une bd cyprien qu'il
ait des gens ont été au rendez vous et
le tome 2 vient de sortir aujourd'hui je
suis très content romuald son robot tom
cette sortie bientôt
ouais ouais corentin compare à tort
revue c'est quoi la différence avec le
tome 1 et barcella suite directe
d'accord avec ba un nouveau méchant une
nouvelle histoire de nouvelles
situations des nouveaux strips pas qu'à
améliorer les dessins il ya plus de
situations il ya plus d'aventuré il ya
plus d'émotions bref c'est tout en mieux
quand vous m'avez convaincu d'acheter la
bd à vous la fait l'atelier d'accord
bonne lecture dorothée en dessin animé
magazine faisait pas d'un dessin animé
vous pouvez nous en dire plus
oui bah je suis super content de bosser
sur un dessin animé roger c'est humain
voilà ça reprend les textes et les
personnages d'accord drôle en fait quoi
sur les dessins animés
j'ai écrit des textes et je fais la voix
de roger le robot est ce qu on pourrait
le comparer au dessin animé titeuf nom
d'accords dont on pourrait plutôt de
comparer à je sais pas moi les cas soc
ou un gars une fille mince et format
court qui voit là une comparer donfut
plaire aux rochers pour trancher
alors pour l'instant je peux juste vous
dire qu'on bosse dessus il n'y a pas
encore de date de diffusion mais dès
qu'on aura une couleur vous la dirai
c'est par sa voix comme réponse ces
bâtisseurs oui je suis désolé why should
retard mag
c'est quoi la différence entre le tome 1
et le tome 2 quelqu'un a déjà posé la
question fac c'est parce que je suis
toujours en retard roxim hâtivement il
l'a fait l'animation mais pas les voir
donc c'est pas du tout ça patrick pour
les cahiers de la précision et y
aura-t-il des dédicaces si oui où et
quand ouais bah oui tout à fait on a
prévu des dédicaces un petit peu partout
en france rien à voir à paris à bordeaux
à toulouse à la rochelle angoulême
mulhouse ce que vous pouvez être un
petit peu plus précis sur le lieu la
date des dédicaces par exemple à lac
près non non mais si vous suivez sur
twitter sur instagram vous aurez toutes
les infos sur le lieu les dates vous
inquiétez pas seraient tenues courtes
très près est-ce que vous pouvez nous
parler du dessin animé les vagues en a
déjà parlé tout à l'heure
j'en étais sûr chanter sur wii vous
allez frapper magazine je me rappelle
très bien donner un verre d'eau s'il
vous plaît il est sérieux lui savourer
comme un temps à faire roger temps de s
juin alors ça a pris six mois d'écriture
fr le tome 2 est pareil pour le dessin
puisqu'en fait pas cas à dessiner les
planches en même temps que je terminais
les effets on en fait j'écris ça en
début d'année en parallèle de la
préparation de mon court métrage lunaire
ou juste moi n'aliène une équipe et
temporelle parallèle mais j'avais la
trame déjà de lui donner c'est terminé
c'est super je dors et déjà six
personnes atteintes en fin de vie tant
comme ya j'ai entendu parler d'un
coffret batta
j'imagine que quelqu'un a déjà posé la
question et ben non en bon c'est vrai
est-ce que vous pouvez nous du coffrage
bien sûr si vous n'avez pas lu le
premier tome il existe un coffret qui
comprend les deux tomes ainsi qu'un pas
porter à construire soi même et sur
amazon et une couverture spéciale du
premier tome ainsi qu'une photo
dédicacée par paca et moi même dans son
coffret au hasard merci est ce aussi à
d'autres questions mais je peux vous
proposer de regarder un extrait du
dessin animé roger c'est humain
maintenant godaddy mission je vais le
regarder de manière très demandé près de
silence quand même et on voulait manger
nul en ehpad soit pas de souci est
d'accord c'est d'abord j'adore la
musique du générique nom et dont congé
tu sers à quoi exactement
et toi égaux tu sais à quoi exactement
est obligé d'être aussi désagréable et
tu sais faire à manger
non mais je peux apprendre quoi tu veux
dire que que j'aurais plus jamais à
faire la cuisine à la salle attend du
patriarcat
on ne regarde pas comme ça c'est normal
c'est la pression de la société avec une
recette se trouver sur internet
j'ai préparé un gâteau pour ton
anniversaire champ mais ce robot
abattant mais le superbe dans le plus
dur était de trouver les feuilles de
cannabis
ton visage tout le monde 11 g cliff trop
strauss et joue la femme voulait parce
qu'arès tous les genoux désolé pour le
gâteau tout à l'heure j'ai fait une
omelette pour me faire pardonner
y'a pas de cannabis j'espère nos cool
j'ai trop la balle et j'ai tous les mois
mais les champignons wac ressent plus
franchement j'ai envie de vous voulez
chez l'oreille à tous mais comme un
copain comme un amoureux tu vois plus on
fait du camping en fait du poney qui
fait le poney de l'ecal plus de cheveux
safar angers elle reculait à vous pèse
je vais en donner aux enfants du
quartier rouge et or en exil à 300 euros
chez 3 suisses enregistraient
l'antimissile prix noir brillant c'est
rien c'est payant et voilà le tome 2 de
roger c'est humain est enfin disponible
absolument partout vous ai cliqué sur un
lien dans la discussion pour la
commander et moi je suis très très fier
de cette bande dessinée j'ai adoré les
crayères je me suis attaché au
personnage et je suis vraiment très très
content de ça j'espère que ça va vous
plaire n'hésitez pas à me fier sur les
réseaux sociaux pour avoir un petit peu
plus d'informations notamment sur les
dédicaces et moi je dis à très vite
[Musique]
là